this is like the most romantic thing
we've done together the most wonderful
aspect of bode dining is that we sit on
the floor
we have this big steel plate called
Ethel which we place on a slightly
elevated surface and and they all eat
from the same place it's like is this
use to clean the palate
before you start your meal so and
activate your taste factor it enjoys
some massage that Okemah it just makes
everything better
money but it's a little I hate smoking I
can feel I can feel it smoky it's just a
regular service mmm just with meat oh
then I'm not gonna be going back to all
you suppose all after this
this is sweet apparently if you
alternate between salty and sweet it
reactivates your palate I really like
this concept in between meals cases
applet normally it has a very strong
taste but overpowering but it's not the
case like I'm gonna be abandoning
schools all together by that kind of a
dish that if no one was looking I would
take like that you can learn the entire
leg of the lamb
you can enjoy - with pretty spicy
I loved the spices this is like an
orgasm rate girl this is bhuna gosht oh
this is more familiar to what we need
generally there are demarcated margins
that we aren't crossing over here you
better have nothing to do for the rest
of the day I've never had bread and rice
is same I haven't done it I think about
hydrant picked out so much in the
previous or should have enjoyed
completely discounting the fact that
we're all falling asleep you remember
that scene where joy comes to eat the
turkey wearing that maternity shirt yeah
that's basically so we just got done
with what has been the best meal of my
life by five in the past Ponyo it was a
nice experience you know what everybody
likes sitting together or and eating and
sharing the same plate I never shy away
from meat but right now I can't bear to
look at Lambeth knows too much my body's
just happy but confused and fools I
didn't even know that boring food was
different or had a style of its own it
just goes to show how much of a cultural
difference there is like within our own
friends okay